okay councils it's just after three so
uh
when you're ready guys thank you so uh
welcome to councils to list the council
meeting
on the 31st of January
um and welcome to the public that are
watching on a live stream and we have a
guest speaker after this which I don't
have on the agenda so Simon up back
there with the uh big on is going
to give us a bit of an update on EMS
which you mentioned Southern Howard
operates remiss of me to not have this
on the agenda so it will take him some
time that was my mistake not yours so
um
so uh we've got apologies from councilor
Peter Kidd and councilor Barry Stewart
who can't be here today
moved secondary thank you oh can I just
put you down for everything you do
um
so moving on we've got nobody in the
public forum
we do have a major light late item which
is the recommendation from the community
well-being committee project 1225
request to amend the Queen's Park
management plan
so that will come in later from today's
Workshop somebody like to move there
it's a layer either oh moved yeah thank
you Leslie and yeah Nigel thank you
so just moving on to the agenda now
we've got a cluster of minutes from
previous meetings to confirm before we
get down to the great South letter of
expectation
just moving through those we've got the
minutes of the bluff community board
held on the 19th of December
somebody recommend that they be accepted
Grant thank you yeah
right about you thinking any discussion
around those
there being nothing uh all those in
favor carried
the minutes from the risk Assurance
meeting
moved on the 20th you thank you Darren
seconded two Thursday thank you any
discussion around those
there being none oh sorry did you wonder
yeah just um sure with respect to the
0.7 around
um
aggressive actions towards staff and so
staff are being trained and how to
manage those situations
mushroom of tall H3 of six I'll truly
grab that microphone really quick so I
think she's putting a hand up to answer
that one through you Mr Beer yes we
provide training for our Frontline staff
and dealing with aggressive customers
that supports our staff to carry out
um their tasks and we also provide
afterwards if there are incidences we
work with them and do debrief and offer
extra counseling Etc as appropriate and
we have a trespass process in place for
those members of the public that it's
not safe for our people to have them on
site or at a facility anymore
thank you
any further discussion
all those in favor
the minutes of the community well-being
moved too quick sorry who was that Trish
Trace thank you Trish
Council
thank you Darren yes council meeting
um any discussion around that meeting on
the 20th of December
there being none all those in favor all
right Kerry
foreign well-being
received yeah thank you Darren
seconded yeah thank you Leslie and uh
any discussion
there being none all those in favor
carried
um the minutes of the phonics and
produce committee on the same day 24th
of January
you'll be the chair you can say yeah I
move that Grant oh yes yes thank you
thank you Lucy reading my night yeah
it's all right that's good
um any discussion around those minutes
yeah being done all those in favor all
right Carrie moving on to the next item
which is tab nine
which is the Great South Cathedral of
the expectation
Rihanna
thank you chair so this paper outlines
um the priorities that were provided to
the Joint shareholders committee at the
time of the meeting and will be
incorporated within the joint South
letter of expectation
which is going to Great South at the end
of this month so we'll be available to
cancel very shortly
so could you just clarify for the new
Council of the process that's involved
here with the letter X both expectation
and the subsequent statement of intent
absolutely so every year we flow through
the same process
um which begins in
um
around August it's delayed this year
because of the elections which is why
the process is a little bit delayed and
the report outlines those dates so we
provide a letter of expectation from the
shareholders
um Great South will then respond where
the draft statement of intent which in
outlines how they intend to meet the
requirements of the letter of
expectation then we will respond to that
if there are any concerns that any of
the shareholders have and then great
South is legally required to provide to
its shareholders the final statement of
intent by the end of June next year
we're in this year
um for those that are new as well
um we've currently got a review of The
Constitution of great Jeff going on
um which looks at that the way we govern
Great South there's a collective of Paul
castles and we've also given some
indication around um
what we have prepared to fund Dollar
Wise and potentially what we prepared to
fund uh outcome-wise which is somewhere
else what the Great South want but
that's the position that we're
indicating
any uh Quest earringy thanks I'll be
just touching on that um funding prior
priority areas are funding here
um I thought we were going to
um put in our expectation that just
transition work regarding you know
obviously Ty closing was to cease
and I don't see it
here because Ty is not closing and why
are we continuing I thought we discussed
that and sort of mulled it around that
that future work was I guess I guess you
I guess the issue around just transition
is wider than just Ty now
um but we don't have a definitive
position from TY yet the negotiations
are still ongoing I understand February
March we will get an indication
that's what I'm hearing from yeah but I
mean like we there seems to be Pie in
the Sky it seems to be an open checkbook
to uh
you know the the using Ty closing as as
a means to just work on on stuff that is
that is frivolous I see that's why and
we're paying for it so I I'm just a bit
more substance
and and stuff we are doing and not
um
I mean seriously is
where are the indications that Ty are
closing
there isn't well there isn't there isn't
a definitive answer on that because the
heavens either with their clothing or
staying open
yeah Tom
through your chair I think
um and you know you recall I shared that
meeting
um rainy I think the decision was it
would remove it from her priorities
which is actually what's happened yeah
just to say that you know we don't want
me to do it at all you know we certainly
never said that we said we'd take care
of her priorities
has been removed from your career list
if you look at prioritarians for funding
and adult points it's not in there
anymore yeah it's not in there but it
doesn't say it doesn't mean what I'm
saying is that
we're not telling them to cease work on
it that's all
you know it's well I guess it's
reasonable to assume if you if you know
the
um the current
um debate we're having with great South
is that given that we're not funding to
the level they want us to fund to uh and
this is not a priority area for us you
can reason me assume that they won't be
going ahead with any more work than they
did okay unless they get external
funding right if you have total faith in
that then I I do have and I've got I
agree with what you're saying I think
just transition will back out of it if
Ty stays open they'll diss be on the
horizon I think
I really well they were here as a
transitional phase
even
um they will support
the point we cannot tell them not to do
something that they have an external
contract for yeah
um we can only ask them to prioritize
what we
have agreed to fund
and given that we have not got it in our
priorities does not mean that they have
to stop it just means that they can't
use any of our funding to do it as I
understand and that was my understanding
of the after the workshop as well so
thank you for the clarification
any further questions
yeah being none somebody like to move
the
um three recommendations we've got there
yep I'll move chip thank you Tom
thank you
all in favor
aye aye carried
and you've got the hot seat again
for the annual plan
in 2024 2034 long term plan strategies
so you'll recall counselors that at the
end of last year you had a paper around
your priorities and the workshop plan
for the long-term plan this is the
second element that relates to those
discussions that you're having at the
end of the last year the Strategic
projects as they relate to the long-term
plan and the annual plan process so this
paper is very much procedural in nature
it's around how the correct information
will be brought to the correct
committees for confirmation of decisions
and direction in terms of how that those
projects relate both to the annual plan
for those that are already in flight and
to the long-term plan
um so my colleague Lee has also been
involved in writing this paper in terms
of when the project management office
will be able to bring specific
information to you I have one correction
that just needs to be made in terms of
the paper because of information that
came came after it had already gone into
your agenda and that is in relation to
rugby park the information will now no
longer be available as early as we
thought it was the earliest it will now
be available is April so
um my understanding is that there it
would be good to look at the option to
bring Surrey Park and Rugby Park
Information together at the same time so
the first opportunity if counselors want
to go in that direction to do that would
be to an extraordinary meeting of
finance and projects in May
so those are just the additional points
since this paper was written
happy to take any questions
um two things from me Rhianna
um
first is the on page 32 a board box is
the urban play
and we've got 49 million investment over
6.5 million dollar project in either
rangi or Alex might be able to help me
with this but it seems to me that that's
one of the projects that we seem to lost
a little bit of sight on as we developed
the inner city
um and interfacing with that is as
Andrea on behalf of Ico late last year
asked us to give some thought to the two
Parcels of land that we have in the Ico
block
the stage we don't have use for and one
of them was the corner of Tay and Kelvin
which is where sit was going to go
that's sitting there vacant and he he
asked us whether we wanted to retain the
land that gave us the cost of doing so
he also asked us um whether it was an
option to sell
and so um I'm just assuming I guess that
that could be an option for some in the
city to even play on that piece of space
which is quite large if we wanted to
retain that we could use it for urban
play in the interim period be It
Whatever the time frame is so that might
impact
um you're thinking around there given
that we've got a paper a bit later on
that um
that looks at that issue as well
so in that case would you like to amend
4A just to include
that as an option for consideration
which can get discussed at the February
I think we should discover because oh
well the land will just simply vacant so
it could read with a focus on nodal or
Digital Play
or
a dedicated play Space
yeah all of those but you'd assume if
you've got some open space here and you
you wanted to retain it it you wouldn't
just leave it sitting there for the next
whatever number years three four five
six seven years whatever you want
um if that's the alternative to um
selling it because that's an option as
well
um then I would have thought that would
be an ideal place to have an inner city
play area
Alex this is now your chance to
contribute
um I would be happy with adding the
amendment to
um the recommendation there
um I know that it's certainly something
that I've driven for with the situation
play across the across the years
um
so yeah I'd be more than happy to see
that
uh rangi do you have any important to
that given you're on that committee
no well obviously I mean my my view of
that site considering it's completely
blocked out from northern sun and
Western Sun yeah
um and wouldn't be the ideal spot for to
play you know
um I mean obviously the identification
of some use would be good but it doesn't
sit high on a priority for me not in not
in play no okay not an urban certainly
not from that streetscapes committee
okay yeah Alex I'll just I've got yeah
on play so we would then uh have that
report come back about what has already
pre-planned in the inner city with the
streetscape developments but also the
node or digital play and potentially
backspace may not be there the place
you've identified but it would allow for
us to have some feasibility about other
sites around the city as well yep no uh
yeah totally have to agree with ringy on
that point I mean that so it's
completely surrounded by tall buildings
um for the north east and west and um
there is a time zone going into the uh
into that new invercargill so I
understand it it's quite a large one so
that will in fact um accommodate some of
the things that you you're wondering
about here sure just as just a point to
consider yeah
there's a range of options that could go
no rush it doesn't have to be a player
it could be just a a green space that
people could sit in everyone's sitting
in the shade there was that because
you're going to be in the shade all the
time yeah it's not the right spot yeah
just signaling that I guess that that's
something we need to give some
consideration to
yes and the last reflection for me um
as the um
the risk profile on page 35.
um
and the risks of delaying some of these
projects or changing the projects
um so um certainly if you look at the
middle one which is changes to the road
map
to
um could damage our reputation I'm not
sure that's the case I mean some of us
canvas quite widely
um pre-election on on the issue that we
wanted to claw back some of the capital
expenditure given the cost of living
impacts on the community and on us as as
a council as well and and and and I know
the rest there is Council fails to fully
understand the needs of external
stakeholders and outcomes are less than
optimal as a result well I think most
Council around here have got a pretty
good feel from the community about
potential rate increases
coming up this year we initially floated
20 which you can imagine what the
response to that would be in the
committee
um and sure having optimal outcomes is
great but sometimes they're not
affordable of they're not available on
the time frames that we have so
thank you for raising those but I'm not
sure I'd actually agree with some some
of the issues in there
any other questions
or reflections
oh ever
um
so going back to the play thing are we
open to the kind of pop-up experiences
that happened in Christchurch with
um vacant places that had no
um
design use in in the interim period and
is that something that
we could encourage but remind the people
who do it that they have to be easily
taken down at their own cost should the
property need be needed for something
else because I as I was sitting thinking
about it I thought that actually
the the space thing is becomes an
eyesore after a while it becomes a block
for people the idea that something
vibrant and active could be in some of
those spaces
is actually quite attractive if we as a
council decided that we could encourage
people who wanted to come up with a good
proposition for a a short-term or
um you know non-permanent type
um in a city activity
um yeah I've got yours all there and
Charlie
um just respond to that um
so um ICL which is our other partner
Scott has raised the issue what do we
want to do with the land and Andrew
bought that photos before Christmas and
I don't we haven't made a decision on
that so we've got a decision either to
sell it
um it doesn't give us a huge amount of
income if we do that and we may not
necessarily have too much control of
what subsequently gets put into that
space and that's another issue again
um or whether we hold it for strategic
purposes maybe five ten years down the
track we might want to build their
ourselves for some reason Art Gallery
new Council building whatever and what
do we do with it in the drum and I agree
with everyone the feedback from our
partner and the block was that we don't
want a vacant space it'll become bloody
ugly so we want to throw it out and say
hey can it be a play area can it be a an
outdoor art area I mean is it a green
space something that doesn't cost us too
much that can be taken down if and when
we need the land so yes the answer
thank you
I think uh Leslie was next
thank you Mr chair I was just going to
suggest
physical and
corn did you get that
I think that's okay yeah
Maria
uh I'm just
um
I I get the idea that we want to be like
other City centers that do have those
allocated spaces available for members
of our public regardless of age to have
interaction with
I guess for me
um when I think about that area on the
corner there I'm worried about traffic
flow
if we're wanting to have physical play
something that you have just added into
the stadium is the um the ball play
thing with toys on Facebook like I worry
about that sort of interaction the ball
goes over so many kids run out to get it
I worry about the impact of safety on
the area so I think we do need to be
mindful about what it has been used for
should that be a play Space how that
looks and feels safety wise I'll come
back to America
um and I hear what you're saying I've
got uh
Trish and then Darren um
but again we're not looking for a
decision today we're just signaling that
as part of that project that Rhiannon
had in the and the paper here is that we
might want to do something there and it
doesn't have to be play it could be
Recreation it could be art it could be
just something you can sit I mean you've
heard the discussion about the tall
buildings around it and some people find
that okay some people don't
um
do we use some of the artboards that
have been created around it as part of a
temporary thing as well to create some
different sort of vibrancing and we've
got a lot of options to consider but
this is not the place for them just
signaling them
and Rihanna's piece of work that we may
want to revisit that and we'll have to
revisit the issue about selling or not
selling
and you wanted to respond
just supporting what you're saying mayor
the only thing that I wanted to draw
attention to is that there is an
opportunity to discuss this at the
February workshop and also that
um it is important shortly in the
process to in order to us to meet the
time frames that we will need to close
down what the scope is for these
projects so that's what this paper is
about how we will do that and it
outlines that the team intends
to allocate funding to enable that work
to be done so that's why that February
Workshop will be quite important to give
clear direction as to what you do or do
not want scoped because that will affect
the cost of that scoping work the more
options that are in there the more
expensive it will be sure trash I'm
happy now really I just I've got an
opinion on how it could be used but I'll
keep it to the workshop yep thank you
Darren no Darren's alcohol any further
discussion ring
um speaking about funding and obviously
the more cash we we free up in our
annual plan then we can do these things
and one thing that's come to light for
me is and I'll see we see each way here
design work for the museum storage
project facility is complete now
that this storage facility is going to
store our collection I understand now
what I've
learned is there is
no set rental fee agreed for this for
the storage of the collection now you're
building an 11 million dollar
facility and if you're the landlord of
that facility you'd want a return on
your 11 million dollar investment now
um I couldn't I can't quite understand
why we sort of don't have that
established here because that is
critical in
and that's moving forward to know we
have a set income coming in for the
storage because this collection is not
owned just by invercargill it's yeah
it's it's a multitude of uh people and I
don't see why the rate payers of
invercargill would be building a free
storage facility
um
there must be some rental and we must at
some stage know what this amount will be
so we can feed it in to our annual plan
and that may free up some cash to to
scope these projects so I'm just
wondering I thought I'd raise it now how
soon can we know what sort of rental
will be for the collection
so let me respond to that before I ask
Claire to maybe have some input as well
it's my understanding that the facility
is built for the purposes of Southland
as opposed to invercargill so it's a
South and wild thing we will hold stuff
in the
Tisbury facility that's not specific to
the city just as you could argue that
our rate pays memory card will pay it
down site more towards the running of a
museum than the other councils do around
town so it's a much wider issue if you
want to raise it and that it won't just
be the storage facility so who's paying
for the storage facility well we've
funded it
correct me if I'm wrong where are you
Michael yes we have paper okay but we're
not getting any any monetary return for
the storage of something that does not
belong to us
well it belongs to us
we own the music current Museum and
we'll own the physically own the future
Museum we get we get Heritage money from
all the four councils and Darren might
be able to clarify how that works
because I'm not 100 sure now
but the facilities are provided here for
the wider community so it's not just
invocable
it covers we will have collection
collections in there and correct me if
I'm wrong down that will come from
smaller museums things outside the city
so it's a regional facility I mean I
remember a year and a half two years ago
talking about this this exact issue
um about whether we should be providing
facilities for invercargill want to be
called invercargill Museum or whether it
would be a much wider scoped Museum and
the latter was was the decision made
um Mr mirror I think that it's possibly
best described as coming from the
regional Heritage rate Regional Heritage
rate is rated across all of the
territorial authorities of Southland
it's a unique rate there's no such thing
in any other other regions of New
Zealand that rate has continued to be
contributed to invercargill during the
years that the museum has been closed as
part of the contribution to the care of
the collection and the changes that have
been proposed have been made on the
basis that the regional Heritage rate
would continue to be available
council could choose to say that is the
rental for the
um collection it could choose to say
that it is for the contribution to the
museum the discussions have been as
Broad and as principled as we will take
these actions on the understanding that
the regional heritage rate will continue
to be collected and continue to be
distributed in a similar manner to that
which it has been in the past
can I ask who decides on the
distribution of the regional Heritage
right
um Mr Mia the regional Heritage rate is
a joint committee of the three councils
it's an important point because it
reminds you that you each have
appointees on the committee it is
cheered by councilor Paul Duffy from
Southland district and I am currently in
discussions with them over ensuring that
their minutes are returned to you in
order that you can receive from that
Council
um and I'm apologize a bit off the top
of my head I couldn't tell you who
cancels councilor sopa is invocable
cities representative on that joint
committee so we do can you tell me right
now how much
um would be available for the storage
facility out of that rate
Mr me and my answer to the councilor's
question would again be that that hasn't
been determined however you slice it for
the storage facility will have an impact
on the museum
what I can tell you is that currently
the regional Heritage rate collects more
money from across the three districts
how do I put this that invercargill city
is the beneficiary of more money than
its rate payers contribute for the
purposes of that activity
I think the last time I looked in the
cargo City contributed like something
like 970 000 and it gets back more than
a million dollars
right but that still doesn't answer the
rental
of the 11 million storage facility
oh I'll do I'll just reiterate what I
said before I think it's fair to assume
that the city wears a disproportionate
amount of the overall
Museum function for one of the better
Words which will be built or and running
of it um and I came to council
just seems like a lifetime ago
um we were wearing the start of course
we are wearing a lot of the Optics as
well
um so we do have a disproportionate
imbalance if you want to look at it that
way but on the other side but sometimes
large cities provide
um Community facilities for a wide
region
yeah
Leslie
thank you Mr Mia
Q CEO I was going to make a similar
point about the regional Heritage rate
I would just ask
um councilor pottinger
who else
he believes could be charged a rental
for that space I'm saying like we're at
the moment we're looking at a
restructure of the governance of the
collection okay so that governance is
changing
um so the collection is an entity on its
own okay and I really I read the paper
that's 4.5 million items now that's
going to be stored at a facility that we
are building from ratepayers money and
surely
um
uh the people who own the collection or
manage the collection would be seeking
you know um that they must be looking at
paying something to store The Collection
it just makes sense you don't build a 11
million dollar storage facilities
just
you know would know with no financial
planner here
to to fund it at least it's operational
or something
yeah so here the issues you raise I'll
come down a minute Nigel but just to
also reflect that we also heavily funded
the stadium
and you the community outside of Macau
which is where the funding comes from uh
give a huge amount of access to that
facility free
so you could apply the same argument to
the stadium and you made very well apply
the same origin to Splash Palace because
I suspect that let's not use a pay
either even though we pay when you're
still probably propping up some funding
there annual basis so I guess when
you're in a large city the argument you
have is do you provide just for your own
just for your own citizens or do you
require those outside that are
potentially coming in
um to have to contribute as well and
that's a debate wider than just
the two three situation it would be the
museum it would be um like in some
cities in the country and if you're
a right parent invercargill you get into
the museum free if you're a right part
of Riverland you pay a fee
so that's what happens in Auckland if
you don't live in the Auckland territory
area you pay to get into the museums I
think that's a discussion we need to
give some thought to at some later stage
if that's what you wished because I
think there'll be quite a bit of
pushback on that on that issue as well
nodule
I think he threw me
um just supporting the mayor and
supporting the CEO it's the issue is
actually much wider than the storage
facility to be honest
um it's a big it's much much broader
than since the southern community and
the opportunity we have
um around that
um and procurement of
of uh Financial resource across a wide
stream to support the actual project
1225. uh we're not playing Robin Hood to
be honest yeah
to be feared we take the high stool on
this one
and because we are going to lean on The
Wider southing community and The Wider
stalton Community Fund is to support
project 1225 it'll be very unwise
um in my opinion to be worried about a
rental on a Salton collection
it's owned by South End southcenters
and in that sense it would be
we are in a very delicate stage of the
starting phase of actually procuring
funding for project 1225
so I think we just need to be mindful of
that moving forward
we've got some fantastic opportunities
and we should be treating them the right
way certainly not a rental on a what is
actually a certain storage facility as
well
you need for further discussion
yeah Tom
I'm probably going to spend a
little bit against the Tate actually in
making these comments but it does send
me a reasonable question to ask how
other parts of Southland are going to
share in the overall cost
of the museum and including the
operating course now it may be that the
answer to that is well not at all we are
going to take the high school we're
going to do it all
but I think we should understand that
and it should be explicit
um I mean if if there are I don't know
if that's the case it if there are
collections for example and various
other storage areas which are going to
be released into Earth in the new
storage area
and that therefore other councils are
going to save on rental for example then
it would be reasonable that you know
some of that would would go away I don't
know whether that's the case so so I'm
not actually arguing for any particular
and what I'm suggesting is that the
question that councilor postinger asked
in a broader context
um of how overall the councils are the
people of Southland will help pay for
this facility that principally we are
providing I think it's a reasonable
question sure
and I wasn't suggesting otherwise but
one of the issues and Darren will be
able to clarify for this for me but a
lot of the outside of invercargill City
storage will not be Council based it'll
be from small Galleries and
thanks me I guess um
there's a mixture so
what is held at the the current site is
in effect a Southland collection that I
don't think you could print on
any one territorial Authority
there are within both Gore and Southland
districts their own museums with their
own storage as well as a variety of
small community and and independent
operations with their own storage there
was some expression that additional
storage space might be required by some
of those facilities and if that's the
case I think there is a case for
leveling a degree of of rent on those
but anything beyond what exists
currently essentially if you want to
charge rent for it you're just going to
be texting yourself because our
contribution to the regional Heritage
fund left to go up to to match that but
anything additional to what's what's
there currently I mean bearing in mind
that when you shift
items of the collection out of the
current footprint you certainly gain use
of of all that footprint for
action activity display so that's why
you're creating the storage facility at
Tisbury thank you Billy
sorry for raising oh sorry Nigel yes now
just to clarify timing and Ian's Point
around the funding of the museum it's
certainly not the intention of this
Council unless you tell me otherwise
will tell us otherwise that we'll be the
sole supported financially of that of
that project
certainly not the intention so it will
be a much wider spread across a whole
realm of community funders and National
funders for sure so we have that we have
our eye on the prize regarding those
particular aspects so just to clarify
for timing in we are certainly it
certainly will not be an ICC in my
opinion and the project team's opinion
sold financial responsibility
sorry for dragging you into that round
we're talking about uh about the ICL
so you've got a bit of a feel there
we've got a wide Suite of um amendments
here I mean recommendations here seven
on but there are actually more than that
would somebody like to move them all or
what's the amendment to four yes yep
thank you there second day there's me
thank you all those in favor
thank you Karen
and you're here again Rhiannon
thank you again you're all be sick with
me so this is the uh 20 22 25 triennial
agreement yes so this is a legally
required document that all councils must
adopt each trianium
um
I'll take the report
that it speaks for itself and I'm happy
to answer any questions
any questions
there's a review underway
give me a clock so I'm happy to move the
three recommendations as there yeah I'm
happy to see him there
um any questions in relation to the
paper
you got away free all those in favor say
aye aye Carrie
Jonathan Wherever You Are
so I might just lead into this one
Jonathan if you can spare me a minute or
two
um so we had a workshop earlier in the
afternoon that looked at this issue
um I guess the general feel out of it
and and this is what we'll need to
confirm today was that the
um
there was a desire for us to be part of
a joint
um submission of the three councils to
central government
but there was some concern around two
key issues
um
one being the issue of the um
us being a pilot scheme or suggesting
that we could be a pilot I think the
feeling at the floor was very much
opposed to that by quite a large margin
so we hopefully will confirm that for
you today
and I guess you'll take that back to
your colleagues and the other councils
[Music]
um
and what was the other one Tom
yeah what were the two issues that you
raised oh sorry the other issue here is
on page 61 probably right of the joint
submission yeah and deals with the
um the issue of the extent to which uh
appropriate rates existing property
rights can be overridden
um by the npf
and the
argument and the debate that we had was
whether
um that actually is something which we
would support as a council and and my
proposition as that we should not
so the point that we're counting
Jonathan obviously you were there was we
hit one or three options we could adopt
what was in the paper
we could ask for that piece and it's
only a small piece to be removed so we
set aside or finally whether we would
actually put a submission a statement
there as part of our submission to say
actually
um we we want to be on the front foot on
this issue to say hey
um
we want some further clarification this
is an important Democrat Democratic
issue around the rights of of the
community over the rights of an
individual property owner and we want
some uh to signal that we want some
further information to be given to us by
central government so that we are clear
what we're advocating for on behalfaire
community
so we've got three recommendations here
um just one thing for you Jonathan in
um in recommendation two it says that
decides to approve this submission and
principle and I think
not sure I like the end printable bit I
think we either support submission or we
don't so subject to any amendments we
suggest to you
we could remove that
I think so would you like to speak to it
now just briefly because we've had this
uh the workshop earlier on
yeah um yep so uh
I think this speaks to
um the difficult the challenge around
submissing its speed when the process is
at speed and that is why I took the
precaution of obtaining an extension so
ICC could submit in their own space on
this
um the report seeks obviously to work on
the joint submission from the feedback
that I've received I will take back to
my colleagues at the other councils
um and as a council officer I'm
recommending that um Council decides to
delegate final approval to cancel a
Ludlow in regard to the Joint submission
taking into account Council a lot like
his extensive experience with the RMA
thank you for that so it might be hell
for us councilors if we just give him a
steer on on the three issues one issue
is do we want to be a in a joint
submission or do we want to go at all
over cable being mindful I think it'd be
very unwise to be doing but it will give
make mixed messages
if the feeling of the day was that we
were preferred the um the joint approach
we need to tell Jonathan that and we
also need to clarify the other two
issues about what we want him to tell
the other two councils around proper
private property rights and whether we
do or do not want to be the one of the
pilot regions as well
uh Tom sorry
um
somewhere just to clarify at a point the
the issue that I had was appropriate
Rights was about the same half of that
paragraph
um I I think counselor soper's
suggestion that we remain we keep the
first two sentences yes I think actually
it's appropriate because the first two
sentences of that don't Point really
just say that they it needs to be
clarified yeah
um and I think that is an appropriate
point to put in there so I would support
the discussion of the comments that
Council of super made in a previous
meeting
so what's the point on which I raise my
hand it seemed a reasonable yeah so I
got there so I'll just have a quick
straw poll I guess the best way to give
Jonathan some uh some feel for where
we're coming from is there anybody
opposed to a joint submission from the
three councils or as opposed to us going
alone
sorry Mia clack can I just clarify a
point because I think there might be
those of us that would support a joint
submission provided there were those
adjustments sure so if the adjustment
around the the second part of property
rights and around being a pilot region
were agreed to by the partners then I
think we would be in support
if the partners weren't in support of
that then
um my read would be that we would prefer
a a standalone submission which is
mostly along the lines of the joint
submission but but with those two
amendments and and and that's the area
to which
I'd be extending that discretion that
item three affords
there just needs to be a a a method that
gives us the opportunity to talk to them
I think sure and so that's the state
I'll come to your ringy that's a steer
we're trying to give Jonathan who's the
go between others with exceptionally
close time frames that yes if we do want
to do a joint one that's great but it is
subject to us having those two issues
resolve if not he needs to come back or
so we exercise the old tender which he
needs to tell him that we'll exercise
our alternative if we don't get our way
I guess if I may have taken the liberty
of sending you all the most up-to-date
version as well yes
ringy ringy look regarding the property
rights
closer or mention of it and then we've
got Michael Morris here just look around
the same generally there is other laws
in New Zealand regarding property rights
that must interface into the RMA RMA is
not sole thing about property rights and
I'm just trying to get into my head how
the AMA can suddenly
um try and clash with other property
right laws we have in New Zealand I'm
just having a guess that there may be
other laws
um regarding the right of someone who
owns a property and that come under
other laws besides the RMA yes I think
my read of what Jonathan's provided us
encouraging if I'm wrong Jonathan um is
that there are lots of competing laws in
New Zealand the RMA will guide the
consent process
for Council as they're proving consent
and that's where the tension will come
when there are opposing pieces of
legislation elsewhere that's correct yep
all me a clerk opposing legal
interpretations which
lawyers I want to do by the very nature
of their professionals lawyers will make
a small fortune out of the RMA so in
that recommendation three we're
um delegates final approval to cancel
hello can we also include final approval
and liability yeah no oh yeah that's
right
it lives approval on a submission that's
not liability it's a government chooses
to ignore it that's okay but I admire
the attempt I just I just thanks Mr Mia
I was just going to point out that the
particular point of page 61 and why we
were discussing it in The Way We Were is
that it particularly deals with existing
use rights which if you like in a simple
form is a subset of general property
rights that is particularly pertinent to
this legislation and it was that
particular point that Tom was Raising
that issue about and I was suggesting
that the
the compromise of the year is that the
first two sentences need to be in
because it is necessary to clarify that
particular subset
um
so it's it's not a matter of
what property right legislation exists
in New Zealand it's a matter of this
particular bill in the particular focus
on existing use rights and whether they
can be altered or extinguished that is
the whole point of that and thank you
for that
so we would the proposal then would just
simply be delete everything after
altered wouldn't it
the um npf needs to establish clear
Direction about the scope which is
imminently reasonable
so uh Jonathan you've got that then the
field there from everybody yep
understood joint one and all God alone
if we don't get away
um and the two issues that we want
result
excellent
so we're comfortable that we have that
regular room in those three
recommendations
well we've got the in principle besides
to approve
the principles subject to suggested
changes yep yeah
we're just I think provide me with a bit
more Comfort around the process
I think Jonathan will uh take that away
we'll get a final
approval for this I take it all it just
go
I think the chair I would agree I think
we would cancel it was saying I think
point two has to have some additional
Woods added
um this would be to say to approve the
submission and principle and the
proposed natural building environment
act and special planning act
um uh with the two
um changes that have been proposed so I
don't think it can be just left us to us
at the moment I think you you do have to
add another phrase
okay
right now
with
the Edition proposed changes around was
it um
around the pilot screen
yep
I'm probably right
yeah
participation in the model scheme
foreign
all right
okay Darren Paul
are you smiling if that's okay
all right so we want to put all three uh
recommendations
rather it wasn't me no
this will be a long minute Ellen and
Grant thank you all those in favor
carried
and the final
thing on a current test before we do the
uh major lathe item it's the issue about
a proposed date and delegation to visit
kumagaya
oh yes so just to give you a heads up
we've had a
very successful visit from our friends
in Japan over the last
three four days
um
recommendation and um
in the early part there's some
suggestion and recommendation three
about who should go
and I'm going to suggest that we
slightly amend that so that we can have
some further discussion about who should
go
and who should be paid we've got a
significant amount of competing needs of
people who want to go now this is not
necessarily from around this table the
kuma guy friendship Association is
prepared to send members who will pay
their own way I want to give some
consideration to Amy as well and I want
to give some consideration too who we've
seen and then we dictate dictated to by
the available expenditure as well
and whether that's based on economy
flights or something better than that
certainly my preference would be on the
economy
and then there are some people some
counselors have said to me I'd like to
go and I'm prepared to pay my own way
and we I want to also consider the
potential that we might subsidize some
councils to go some members to go at 50
and some people may take that up as well
so I don't want to make a decision today
if I can afford it
um I want to have uh we can have a
counselor only Workshop somewhere along
the line in the very near future given
that we need to book flights fairly
quickly but there are quite a few
parties I need to talk to still
so Mr Mayor would you like
um numbers one and two of the
recommendations moved then yes and I
think we just at this stage we just
moved the um unbudgeted expenditure as
well so it gives the committee an idea
of what money's in bulk
yeah and we leave out who the delegation
actually is
let me ask him sure
to check whether the chief executive's
team have actually done some sums to
look at whether that 35 000 is realistic
understanding Career Fairs are heading
these days yep Claire that's to me at
the uh figure was originally uh based on
four at premium economy fears because of
the length of the travel and included
four nights accommodation uh my comment
would be that you are right that the if
is are considerably more and that with
my understanding is that they continue
to move upwards
I
have some concerns that that may be
insufficient
if we are delayed in organizing
can I just ask the need for
premium economy just noting that I did
quite a bit of traveling on economy
around the world in 2019 and had
absolutely no no I am a short ass but
you know I had no problem
an economy whatsoever so I'll respond to
that ringy because I have had some
discussions also with the chief because
you're going to have this in regards of
the price involved between the two
um I I would only be comfortable with
economy
and if you can't deal with economy then
I guess you don't go because I think the
public
um are quite skeptical of these systems
that you visit anyway so we should
travel the cheapest way we can
that may give us a little bit of money
to start getting some cross subsidies of
paying half of somebody's right here as
opposed to the whole right yeah I would
suggest that you probably leave uh item
three out completely because to be
honest that's a that's a that's a very
uh unrealistic amount
you're going to spend it way more than
that just for the three years I know
they're already because I've been
booking trips myself yep
so just to leave the whole three out and
rise again after discussions yep happy
to have a council on your time and for
staff to give us some advice I'll put it
down a little bit of research
Lizzy you did suggest that just one or
two um so I'm happy to move one and two
and I'm happy to move up to budgeted
amount yeah because I think it's it is
important to have that indication in the
public position
we need to come back we come back
a signal
yeah thank you Tom all those in favor
aye Carrie
and we just have the one late item now
Mr Meek can I just um sorry I actually
opposed that so can I have that noted
please absolutely yes sorry I should
have recognized it
and we'll record that
um
and we also have the major late item
which is the issue of the recommendation
from the community well-being committee
earlier this afternoon
around project 1225
request to amend the Queen's Park
management plan
thank you mayor Clark the um majority of
people were here for that um
extraordinary meeting it's really
procedural the recommendations one
through five I'm happy to move the
recommendations from the extraordinary
meeting to council I'll second that
thank you any discussion around that
and they're being none put into the
Bible those in favor
aye Carrie
and now we close our oh no we stand open
um I believe in the ship that you were
wanting to yes
Simon yeah
um are you wanting to do that within the
construct of council yes okay yes I
think we'll leave that over because I
think there'll be people who will be
live streaming be interesting what you
have to have to tell assignment so
welcome to council and Mr mean to not
have us on agenda because we did discuss
it
um and just to give a bit of a lead into
Simon's presentation we had um
a meeting of me as recently and some
some Chief Executives around EMS which
is Emergency Management Southland
one of the leading setups in the country
if not the leading setup for this type
of work gives a lot of praise for what
they do both here and and afar but it
was obvious to me that I think a lot of
councils would not have known actually
what the process is and if we watch
what's happened and um
or they are mere Brown and Auckland
recently and the technicalities that get
on there I thought it'd be really
helpful to have a presentation for you
Simon so welcome
thank you Mr Mayor uh chief executive
um and I'd just like to acknowledge
Mrs cook who is also on a keg uh thank
you for this time I've only got a short
time so I'm going to concentrate on um
councilor's role before during and after
a response however what we would like to
do is invite the counselors to our
emergency coordination Center where we
can do a deeper dive into the
functionality of an emergency
coordination Center and also into how we
uh how we go about declaring or giving
that advice to declare
so Emergency Management Southland unlike
other regions with similar Council
structures
have combined our local and Regional
Emergency Management to make one
Emergency Management Group that's
situated at environment Southland
grounds and it's uh it's uh governed by
the shared services agreement as you can
see we are a small team but we do
provide a 24-hour seven day a week
on-call roster that's shared amongst the
staff
our BAU sees staff kept busy with
training planning updates promote
promoting Community preparedness and we
also manage the AFA or the Alpine fault
magnitude 8 program
which currently has three staff
foreign
[Music]
preparedness relies heavy heavily on the
connection that we have with the
Southland communities and our key
stakeholders
as our team is small we rely on the four
councils to supply staff fulfilling the
function roles within a response
to an emergency
and what we found is after two years of
covert Council staff changes and the
almost complete change of the emergency
management team we're now in a structure
of retraining so we have a training
program ready to go four
um
for the next year
the core of our response
to communities
is our community response plans
and Community hubs now we have five up
there that are relate to the
invercargill and in total we have 26 of
these Community hubs
what we've realized is communities
naturally come together in disasters and
offer assistance to each other what
these Community hubs provide is a
framework that they can follow and
ensure that people get the correct Care
at the correct time
it also opens our communication to the
community hubs
to uh to organizations organization
organizing the community Hub and the
needs assessment and information sharing
our team is currently working with South
alive and developing developing a
community plan for South invercargill
so our overarching legislation is the
civil defense Emergency Management act
and that is sets out the powers of the
director of the national controller and
who can make declarations
it sets up CDM groups and requires there
to be a national C Dem Strat strategy a
national CDM plan and for our groups to
have group plans and we're currently
going through that process at the moment
and it sets out duties of government
departments Lifeline utilities and local
authorities
so this slide shows our reporting
structure uh The Joint Committee of
Mayors and chairs or delegates and
councilor cookers the chair of that
particular joint committee at the moment
and The Keg or the coordinating
executive group is made up of the
council Chief Executives and major
stakeholders and Claire is the chair of
that uh that group
um changes to the CDM act that are
happening at the moment are likely to
see legislative reporting to iwi runanga
and changes to the lifeline obligations
of reporting
so
the role of elected members uh before an
emergency as councilors you're in a
perfect position to understand the risks
faced by the community that you serve
and understanding the areas of the
concern within that community
it is a good idea to know the
controllers and Pim staff who are our
media spokespeople sorry our media
providers to our spokespeople uh prior
to an emergency so that those
connections are already made and that
trust is developed and I have uh
literature here that will actually
support the documents that they see
before you
the role of elective members during a
response in response communities need
that reassurance uh the voice on their
behalf as elected officials you are in a
unique position to actually provide that
information into the ECC
it is important that the information
provided to people in a response is the
correct information and as we know that
can be distorted very quickly and can do
and can cause undue undue concern to our
communities
um it is then that your responsible
voice can assist greatly in these times
as as you know um
after a response
um
we need the listening of the community
this may include being the voice of the
community being the eyes and ears on the
ground Gathering the views and concerns
from the community and feeding them into
the recovery process
um recoveries are a long tail and they
can take an extreme amount of time when
you consider Christchurch is still in a
recovery phase
um and Auckland is set to be in an
extremely long recovery phase
ensuring appropriate scrutiny and
provision of resources to the recovery
team
ing the issues of your community and
local Authority and to the recovery team
most emergency events are followed by a
phase of recovery which may be
formalized within the appointment of a
recovery manager and the announcement of
a transition to recovery
whilst see them will still be involved
of the recovery the focus will often
return to local authorities and other
organizations as they Implement their
recovery plans
above all during these times of response
when um the community is going to demand
a lot of your time what we recommend is
being prepared yourselves I know from
personal uh experience that when you're
responding to an emergency
you cannot do that effectively unless
you know everything back at home is
running okay and that the people are
safe there so we ask you to look at your
preparedness visit our website and
ensure that you're prepared for an
emergency
thank you very much
so we'll come to some questions but I've
got a couple for you so much um
so
when we give advice or comms out to the
community do we have a facility where we
can give to part of a community as
opposed to the whole geographical
community
uh so if we have flooding just in one
suburb or a couple of suburbs can we
target them communication wise
um yes yes we can we have a public
information management team so we love
acronyms and see them
um and we call them Pim and they provide
that information we can Target them
through a number of means um and I know
three of the councils have an antenno
app which means they can ring fence
certain areas of uh of uh Southland to
ensure that that communication is
directly to them however what we find in
emergencies is that everybody's really
interested in what's happening and
normally Southland wide is is uh
the way that it's done so I've got two
other questions
um during the covert period
collectively our region probably had a
leadership group that totaled about 50
60 agencies that readily zoomed in you
can recall and that quite that came in
quite handy at times when there were
people when we had the natural disaster
last year which people scoff at but
which was the drought as opposed to
having a flood or an earthquake so
that's that capacity is still available
built in with the other agencies uh yes
I think think Mr May you're talking
about the regional leadership group that
was started by Southland sedem but is
now legislatively taken over by the
ministry for Social Development
um but uh just recently uh just prior to
Christmas we called an urgent meeting to
talk about two items one of them being
the water sorry the weather conditions
within Southland and the second one
being a foot and mouth incursion and
what that would mean to sell sure
and the last thing is a bit of a curly
question I don't want to trap you anyway
but I know you've had involvement with
the west coast and Nelson and you'll
have seen what's going on in Auckland
do you see things in there that we could
learn from like it you know was was um
I mean everybody's on top of what
supposedly has gone on in Auckland and
and the announcements were late and who
who caused the announcement who gives
advice to the person that causing it
makes the announcement on the emergency
um what what what what do you see and
I'm not trying to get ahead of any
review that's going on in Auckland that
you might have seen in Nelson and West
Coast that would give us a bit of a
steam
and we might have traditionally done
things that we might subsequently do
things a little bit different uh yeah I
do uh thank you Mr Mayor I think I think
it
um quite right to say that there's never
been a perfect response in the entirety
of Emergency Management and every every
response to an emergency is different
due to the fact that every emergency is
different even though one flood could
look very much like another
we deployed staff and I miss myself
deployed to Westport and we got a number
of learnings from that even to the fact
of having a well-equipped ECC ensuring
everybody's got seats to go to and
there's a good computer network
the value of of public information
cannot be disregarded and I think when
you see a good response it's normally
followed by an exceptionally good Pim
team luckily enough in Southland we
utilize the expertise of the four
councils media teams and we're well
served in that fact
um we just today deployed one staff
member to Auckland
um we've got a couple on leave but we'll
be deploying more um as time
layouts
um and yeah that's that's about where I
can yeah understand that yeah Ellen you
wanted to ask I was just going to ask
you where's your Staffing are they
full-time trained Personnel working on
your in your department the entire time
that's correct yes yeah
ringy
um
I just like to talk about preparedness
and
with regards to Auckland obviously if
you've got Med office which is like it's
not like white Island where you're
trying to protect a volcano going well
but with weather satellites you can
gauge you've got
300 mil of rain that's going to be
delivered in a very short time and
and you've got a rough idea of that time
you've got a rough idea of the tides
coinciding now
how obviously we we obviously look at
what our meteorologists tell us and if
we saw an event coming that was going to
dump a lot of water in a short time and
the tides oh that's not good that's the
wrong high tide are we do we have access
to sandbags and deployment of sandbags
and preamps where
um the city stormwater
may not hold is the airport at risk
these things when it are we one step
ahead really to go rather than trying to
find has anyone got sandbags or has
anyone yeah
um uh uh thank you for the question
um so a part of our community health
preparedness is ensuring that we can
look after our communities or our
communities have the framework to look
after themselves we're constantly in
conversations with the infrastructure
teams in all four councils to ensure
that they can highlight areas of concern
and that extends beyond the councils to
our Lifeline department so uh for
instance telecommunications power
networks Etc and we've we can identify
where there may be fragility within
those Networks
um the Met service is only one form of
information that we get
um so for instance at the moment with
our big dry spell uh the ability for
water to be absorbed by the soil is
somewhat reduced
um even though we have an extreme soil
moisture deficit so there's a number of
factors that come into that but uh
basically the Met surface have got to a
stage now when they start giving red
warnings we start paying attention
obviously
um and there is the ability to declare
early if things are likely to happen so
then we can put a lot of things into
play no that's good and my last comment
is great to see you guys have a
dedicated team for aipact
um it seems to be every Council report
seems to be more focused on climate
change
uh yeah thank you that team's been
um going for seven years now I believe
um and has a really good connection with
the science community and is able to
give
um some pretty uh dire predictions of
that AFA
event excellent thanks Tom
um may I ask who the connection walks
between
your stuff
and and see you know chief executive
stuff
and the event of an emergency I'm not
talking about in terms of day planning
and so forth but when an emergency
occurs you obviously have some people
who you can throw in there but the the
foot soldiers and the servants and the
you know will actually come from the
councils themselves I assume so as a
Emergency Management plan which the sea
itself has
the Emergency Management plan is part of
the regional one we don't have our own
we have business continuity plans but
not Emergency Management planning we
provide the opportunity for staff to
have Sims training the training for how
to use the systems at civil defense and
currently I think we have about 17 staff
and we've got about 30 lining up to do
it over the next year
we have a range of staff that some who
need to be focused here and some who
contribute to Simon's portfolio and
responding to an event as and when it
happens yeah so I I guess you know
thanks for that but I guess my question
was
we let's suppose we do realize that
there's a flood event coming and you
know picking up and kind of support and
just point we need 5 000 sandbags at 10
000 sandbags
um your staff have people that call are
the counselors personally who can
actually make that happen
is that the case uh yes yes because
physically you cannot possibly do that
obviously no no so the uh as I say the
the infrastructure whether it be
sandbags or another uh flood prevention
device
um that infrastructure is held by the
councils and the lifeline utilities
um what I will say at the moment is is
there's a number of staff from all four
councils that are undergoing a training
program and as I said in the in the
presentation after two years of covert
we've been unable to uh train people uh
thoroughly through those uh those
programs we've just developed a new
training program that has an
introduction
a foundation course a Sims course and
then goes into function managers course
and we can explain that more if you pay
a visit to the ECC of exactly what those
functions cover but in answer to your
questions I don't know if we've got a
secret well I know we haven't got a
secret stash of sandbags we certainly
have enough
to supplement the stock banks in certain
areas that require that but no we don't
Supply sand bags too no no I mean I
mentioned sandbags what I was meaning is
that in the event of a a an Emergency
where either it's occurred then we know
that it's going to occur tsunami or a
you know Heavy Rain or whatever
um does your people click into gear and
I know that you know the mayor's
clicking again because you have to
declare the emergencies and understand
that my question was about the you know
thousand people or so that you might
want to have to support the underneath
that and how that interfaces with your
people and who fires are trigger than
that and is it a plan to provide those
yes
yeah so the mayor declares an emergency
and then the responsibility comes to the
controller
I think the counselor's question is
partly Simon how well do we coordinate
yes because the power to declare the
emergency and the power to administer or
control the emergency actually realize
on the people here and the rest of the
people in this organization and the
other organizations because it
physically doesn't work
and there's a range of people that come
into play We would typically probably
look towards Aaron and her team because
there'll be issues about roading and
we'll need contractors out and and I
have to say that in most areas there's a
reasonably well-oiled machine
um
it's really good if you have a number of
close calls because it certainly keeps
the machine well-oiled well practiced
and there are people that know that
these are the things that we should be
doing now we had some flooding in 2020
and you were in the role then Simon uh
no I wasn't it was a group controller
but I was the uh an alternate controller
that did take a control at that time so
the the reason we have five permanent
staff in there is is making those
connections at all times talking about
the fragilities of networks and ensuring
that where possible we can actually we
can mitigate those issues
um obviously in in an Auckland event
like the rain that they had it's pretty
hard to mitigate against I think it was
nine times more than they've ever had
eight terms here
and there is also another there's an
operational subcommittee and from here
Trudy is
um the member on that along with her
colleagues from the other Council so we
do keep meeting to talk about what do we
need to be on top of in the planning
any other questions
um could I suggest Simon that you give
some thought to tearing up a visit
um
preferably lightning happening it'll be
good time with one of our meeting so
that people can go from here to there or
go there first
um so a number of our councils actually
work as well
I know some would argue that being on
councils work as well
um because if you haven't been here it's
a really interesting place to go to and
it's good to know what happens there
before you actually need to go there in
an emergency situation so if you can
give some four to a date at a time that
would be great for everyone as I say
I've got some documentation here that
we've just talked through a response
yeah and also some preparation household
plans that magnet to your fridge yep so
I'll leave them yep thank you for your
time thank you very much excellent yes
thank you thank you
all right being there being no other
business and oatmeal
somebody like to move we go out of
or into public schools
thank you Leslie
Grant thank you all those in favor say
all right carried